greetings [ __ ] welcome to mad
flavours world
it's Monday your main man Joey Coco Diaz
and your co-host skinny 50 in the house
relax this Monday cut something what do
you have to worry about let me tell you
some it's all it's like we told you we
got some videos coming up you're gonna
see me and my man getting some ice cream
for the Mexican ice cream man Trini and
some ice cream and me going to the beach
jumping in like a [ __ ] I don't know
what it looks like from behind so thank
you don't forget to sign in for a math
flavor world and tell your friends
there's the party's about to start
[ __ ] I'm also posting a blog pan on
blogger which will be on Twitter and
Facebook all right have a great week
check out these videos you know love it
say goodbye see anything that's my baby
catch a few waves it's a beautiful day
to be alive
look at this
for months on stage I've been talking
about how lucky I am that I got the
Mexicans [ __ ] ice cream man and
now he's here you understand me i'ma
prove it to you [ __ ] it's the
best ice cream ever understand me this
guy shows up whenever it's like 8:30
right now in California and this guy
shows up whenever the [ __ ] you want so
check out the check out the operation
[ __ ] this is the [ __ ] right here
not me though and I eat those number the
older they get to number ones that's how
I roll you understand me this is the
fact he got everything he got frozen
[ __ ] bananas he got cops
he's got Chi he's got everything my book
math Labor's world check out that [ __ ]
at all just like Dairy Queen and just to
let you animals know let me tell you
something my co-host skinny Finny is
ready to rock check him out get some ice
cream [ __ ]
hurry up see I take care of my little
skinny funny check Maya is eating that
[ __ ] little ago that's a real [ __ ]
cat right there that's a savage that's
my men all right that's it [ __ ]
you get nothing
look it's like the last ponies ever
gonna be live you don't know what to do
with himself just like mr. softy in the
old days I told you over here of mad
flavors world you get to see everything
swimming but this is my last ice cream
cone I told you I'm going away watch
this when I seen that tape of me running
back out of the beats like [ __ ] the
blonde chick in ten my titties were
bigger than hers I'm back I'm going back
for wave watches I'm starting like 295
I'm dropping down to like 250 and it's
easy cuz I'm gonna do it and you
[ __ ] to do with me every week
pound for pound countin points this is
the last car I don't get a lot of these
anyway
my [ __ ] is protein I'm a protein [ __ ]
scavenger but I'll be back [ __ ] to
stay black
you
what's happened to beautiful people
welcome to mad flavours world it's
[ __ ] August get your [ __ ] together
it's me and my co-host skinny fitting
that's right we're putting out a video
for you this week he's on a [ __ ] roll